this program is brought to you by Emory
University
good afternoon everyone maybe your
attention please wow I'm thank you I am
so glad to see everyone this afternoon
and to mark another event in the
calendar of the emeritus college and we
like to talk about this is our inside
picnic so here we are on a beautiful
spring day gathered to enjoy each
other's company and to have it I have a
picnic and listen to the remarks of our
guest speaker I was starting with a more
formal introduction and I was going to
Professor Paul mrs. chef and Friends of
the emeritus college it is my pleasure
to welcome you to this is the 8th annual
chef distinguished lecture on creativity
in later life the chef lecture is
particularly meaningful I think this
year because it continues the theme of
the recent Emory conference creativity
through the life cycle as many of you
will know the Center for faculty
development and excellence also a part
of the office of the senior provost for
academic affairs was one of the
co-sponsors of that most engaging
conference the creativity of our
distinguished guest speaker today was
showcased during that conference
thinking particularly of April
seventeenth with the performance of his
musical Jubilee gym but we will perhaps
hear more about that later the chef
lecture is made possible by very
generous gift from Madhuri and jag death
dish chef both of whom are much loved
members of the Emory community mod who
chef is with us today and I will ask her
to stand so that we may show her our
appreciation
mod who thank you for providing us this
opportunity to gather to enjoy each
other's company and benefit from the
words of thought-provoking speakers and
please give our regards to Jack when he
returns he's I'm sorry he's in India now
yeah a second we'll give him our very
best regards and thanks many people have
contributed to the success of this day
and i will name those whose
contributions have been so important and
asked you to hold your applause until
the end i extend my sincere thanks to
the emory alumni association for their
co-sponsorship and for making it
possible for us to meet in this lovely
venue Leslie Wingate and Martha Fagan
been particularly helpful thank you both
very very much the teaching and
lecturing committee of the emeritus
college which was has only been this
committee has only been in existence a
few months jumped into action to advise
and guide the process that has brought
us here today my thanks to the chair
John gunmen Betty Connell Ron Johnson
Ron Frank kv-3 Vikraman and Gretchen
Schultz all of whom participated in this
event as always we have the
behind-the-scenes crew busily at work
and I want to thank we have to program
coordinators to thank today charity
Crabtree and Isha Edwards and joining
them at the registration table which is
Joe on Joe and Dalton so my thanks to
all of you who have been named
to our retired faculty and friends it's
a pleasure to see you today and I take
this opportunity to extend the
invitation for you to visit the new home
of the emeritus college your emeritus
college and if you look at your little
program with Bobby Paul on the front and
on the back is the home of the emeritus
college now in the loose center a
neighbor we're in our own neighborhood
here the loose center is directly behind
the miller ward house come see us all of
you and be an active participant and an
active member we welcome everyone it is
now with pleasure that I will turn over
the program to our chair of the teaching
and lecturing committee John gunmen John
is professor of emeritus of social
ethics and also on the executive
committee of the emeritus college so a
busy person John
thank you nan pleasure to be here and
it's an honor and a great personal
privilege to introduce our two hundred
2011 chef lecture and creativity in
later life for most of you in this room
professor Robert Hall known almost
universally at Emory as Bobby Paul needs
little introduction given the many
important roles he has played and
offices he has held during his almost 35
years at Emory most of these are noted
in brochures that went out for the
lecture and there's no need to repeat
them here for any skeptics I can simply
assure you that he had the requisite
academic preparation to be on the
faculty here for this occasion though I
begin with the question what do the
following have in common Tibetan and
Himalayan culture and religion the
Atlanta Opera and the New York
Metropolitan Opera ritual and myth
psychoanalysis early 20th century
immigrants and the labor movement in New
York City Kurt Vile's threepenny opera
comparative Buddhism a personal art
collection including especially asian
art and artifacts the writing of plays
and musicals a love for Miss or skis
botas goodand off an award for creative
teaching the founding of institutions of
learning and creativity an award-winning
book any guesses the answer is that
everyone in heaven knows i've probably
missed many belongs on professor paul's
list of interests and achievements and
the cross fertilization among them make
him one of the most creative members of
the emory faculty enriching our
lives at every level I can think of no
one more qualified to speak to the theme
of creativity in later life just a few
specifics trange and cultural trained
and cultural anthropology with special
interests and cultural myths and
religion of tibet nepal the himalayas
and South and Central Asia professor
Paul's Restless mind led him early to
pursue study and other fields and to
think broadly about the human
imagination creativity and the human
drama in 1987 he began clinical training
in psychoanalysis becoming certified as
a psychoanalyst in 1997 and continuing a
practice to this day almost immediately
he founded Emery's highly regarded
psychoanalytic Studies program that
institute was also one of the primary
sponsors for the conference on
creativity to the life cycle that nan
just mentioned his early courses on
psychology were not merely a on seminole
figures in the field but for example on
Young and the mythic imagination his
students have praised his creative
teaching and his capacity for drawing on
their imaginations in the interpretation
of texts and of human culture such
teaching won him the crystal Apple Award
in 2000 is the imaginative explorations
of symbols myths and meaning was all has
also been articulated in stunning
scholarship including his book Moses and
civilization the meaning behind Freud
smith published 1995 by yale receiving
three distinguished national awards
including the National Jewish Book Award
these few highlights gives some
indication of extraordinary
contributions professor Paul is made to
the role of art and creativity in
Emery's academic life but there's so
much more professor Paul writes plays
and musicals he has written I understand
how five musicals the one just produced
in a reading yet at the creativity
conference and he writes the music for
them one of the musicals the rise of
David Levinsky played in New York in the
1980s
I think at the 92nd street why correct
based on a book by abraham cohen the
musical gives expression to jewish
immigrant life in new york at the
beginning of the 20th century one of
Bobby's many interests and passions the
play was recently revived in Florida
enabling Bobby to take his son to see it
for the first time he and his wife
Leslie are avid opera fans and Bobby has
a special love for Russian opera he's
the collector of Tibetan and Asian art
and artifacts in keeping with his view
that living a life surrounded by art and
every sense and the notion of applying
aesthetic ideals to all aspects of your
life as the way life should be
vice-president rosemary McGee who wishes
very much she could be here today having
been professional pole student and then
having collaborated with him for many
years speaks of and I quote a veritable
symphony of synchronizations
synchronicities a kind of poetry in
motion and many dances of possibilities
all speaking to Bobby's commitment to
the arts as a special way of knowing and
being in the world one last word there
is a story that at a gathering of the
ILA faculty Bobby picked up the karaoke
mic and broke into a splendid rendition
in German of Mack the Knife Mackie
Messer I don't know whether we will be
repeated treated to anything from Kurt
Weill today I think the mic is not made
for it but I do know we are in for a
treat join me in welcoming professor
rubber Paul
well thank you for that introduction and
thanks John and Nan for inviting me to
do this I'm very honored to do it you've
heard of all kinds of various things
I've dabbled in in my life but of course
my most recent experience was being Dean
at the college for nine years a post
from which I just stepped down last
summer and when I was given the tightly
the topic of this conference this this
lecture and also the conference
creativity throughout the lifecycle
creativity in later life it was a very
creative suggestion I thought in all
kinds of directions but in the end I
kept coming back to wanting to talk
about some observations that I wanted to
give voice to now that I no longer the
Dean but that I could that arise from my
experiences in academic administration
so I won't be talking about back than I
for about Tibet or about the arts really
at all about or Russian operas but I'm
going to talk about the academic the
career trajectory of an academic and
some of the threats and some of the
challenges that it faces so let me begin
it is certainly a great honor and
privilege to be asked to deliver the
annual chef lecture and of course I want
to begin by expressing my deep
appreciation to the chef family to
module and jog when I regret that jug is
not able to be here for their manifold
generous and far-seeing contributions to
the intellectual life of Emory
University our community is very much in
their debt for the efforts they have
made over the years to encourage lively
forums for the best of scholarly
exchange the mandate for the chef
lecture at the emeritus college is the
broad topic of creativity in a later
life and I'm inspired by this theme to
use the occasion to reflect back on my
years as an academic administrator at
Emory where I have served in each in
such capacity
as a department chair chair of the
college tenure and Promotion Committee
dean of the graduate school and from
2001 through 2010 as dean of the college
of arts and sciences the general subject
on which I wish to speak is that of the
academic career trajectory and some of
the issues that attend both those who
choose to live it and those who as
administrators manage and oversee it for
those who have chosen it more
specifically on the wise principal write
what you know I will be speaking mainly
about the career trajectory of
tenure-track professors in the arts and
sciences but I believe much of what I
have to say may also concern other
members of the university community as
well the life of a professor at a great
research university such as Emory is it
seems to me intrinsically creative first
insofar as the successful tenure track
professor is required to produce
original research which in turn can be
defined as the production of new
knowledge any minimal criterion of
creativity is already met equally
importantly teaching two is the
supremely creative act of contributing
to the intellectual and often enough the
emotional or ethical formation of a new
generation of unique individuals whose
very being in the world is shaped as
much by those who teach them in school
college and graduate school as by anyone
except perhaps their parents and their
immediate family finally a truth I did
not quite believe when I first heard it
from my friend and colleague rosemary
McGee one of the ablest administrators
I've ever known but came to realize in
my own experience academic
administration to involves almost
nothing other than an endless series of
problems puzzles and conflicts the
resolution of which is necessarily
always a creative one of course it is
possible to do each of these things in
ways that are only minimally creative or
not at all one can create something that
looks like research through the
rehashing or recycling of old ideas
one's own or those of one's predecessors
one can be repetitive boring and
effect on one students is minimal and
certainly an administrator can be a
bureaucratic hack or a rigid enforcer of
shop Warren rules and procedures
straight from a handbook I must say
however that in my experience at Emory
reviewing the files of candidates for
promotion and tenure for example both as
a faculty member on the tenure and
Promotion Committee and then again as
Dean this depressing portrait is very
much the exception and not the rule this
is because in my experience both the
self selection of professors as those
who by temperament actually enjoy and
thrive upon good research and teaching
and sometimes even good administration
as well as the rigorous selection
process that windows the field beginning
in graduate school and continuing
through the competitive demands of
getting hired being evaluated and
promoted after a provoked probationary
period to a tenured position all these
ensure that most professors are actually
very good at what they do and would like
to be able to keep doing it so I have
now established that the academic career
trajectory and this of course goes not
just for those in the Arts and Sciences
is potentially ideally and often enough
in fact a very creative life the next
question suggested by the theme of the
chef's lecture though is how long can
one keep this up we'll promising and an
eager new assistant professors excited
about their research and energized by
their new teaching duties sustain this
enthusiasm so the 35 years or so later
they will still be doing their jobs
creatively instead of through dry habit
rote repetition or lifeless routine I
guess there's your answer there are
opposing views on this score to some
observers of the academic seen it is the
seasoned full professors who having
spent a lifetime with their field of
study and their own thoughts can produce
the most powerful and authoritative
research and can teach with the deepest
and broadest comprehension of the field
on the other hand one can also argue
that those same seasoned professors
perhaps overly seasoned have undergone
their training decades earlier earlier
in graduate school are far from the
cutting edges of new developments in the
field and are still trying to solve
problems that engage the field when they
were graduate students but have long
since been transcended by new
discoveries new theories and methods or
by the intellectual fashions and fads of
the times the professor in the classroom
reading from dog-eared dusty yellow note
scrawled years earlier is of course a
commonly invoked image if a caricatured
one but i would ask does the fact that
the pages are dry mean that the
professor is as well she may be
repeating herself but the students
hearing the material for the first time
may nonetheless experience a revelation
in short however the question remains do
professors age like fine wine or do they
gradually lose steam and exhaust the
vitality that imbued their early work
with the creative spirit perhaps the
most interesting contribution to the
understanding of the process of
creativity in later life that I have
encountered is to be found in the book
old masters and young geniuses by the
University of Chicago professor of
economics David Galen ssin published in
2007 hopes up you may have read it if
not I highly recommend it Galen ssin
focuses on artists to develop his theory
but he also indicates that his findings
he shows may apply to scientists and
other scholars as well briefly Galen
sins argument is that there are two very
different styles of creativity which he
calls the experimental and the
conceptual experimental artists spend a
lifetime exploring the world as they
perceive it striving for an le never
fully formulated ideal toward which
their actual works of art serve as so
many cumulative attempts to capture some
truth about the world worked out in the
actual process of creating the artwork
conceptual artists by contrast see the
artwork as a realization of an
innovative idea that is preformed so
that the work of creating the arc art
really takes place before the actual
execution which itself can
is merely putting on canvas and already
fully realized thought Galen ssin argues
that the experimental artists generally
speaking has a career that involves a
gradual evolution in which the finest
works are produced last when a lifetime
of engaging with the medium and the
world leads to deep masterworks
therefore these artists tend to be most
creative later in life conceptual
artists by contrast would be hampered by
long immersion in the problems of the
art history of the moment since what
they seek is a new idea instead they
brush aside convention and come at their
work with a bold and innovative concept
that at its best transforms the field
typically such artists accomplished
their great work at an early age and
often either if they don't die young
live if they do live long rarely
replicate their earliest dramatic
conceptual breakthroughs Galen sins
employers of these two styles of
creativity picasso and saison the former
a great conceptual artist the latter a
great experimentalist what a so novel
about Galen sins approach is his method
he uses the tools of an economist to
establish the relative greatness or
creativity of an artist / and then
correlates these with the ages at which
the greatest accomplishments are
achieved by looking at such indicators
as the relative prices at auction of
paintings by the two painters when they
were at different ages the frequency
with which paintings from their
different artistic periods are
reproduced in text books on the history
of art and the paintings chosen by
museums for retrospective exhibits of
the artists work Galen ssin creates a
persuasive quantitative measure of when
the artists originality was at its peak
remarkably each of these measures
produces exactly the same result Picasso
was at his greatest at age 26 when he
broke with existing traditions and
working together with Brock and to some
extent Gris invented cubism which
reoriented the entire subsequent history
of art although he lived a long life
nothing he could
dated later in life is rated by the
collective judgment of those who buy
sell write about and curate art as equal
to such early masterpieces as late
demoulas el divino painted in 1907 when
the artist was 26 by contrast saisons
greatest work judged by the same
criteria and methods are those exactly
all of them point to the same at finding
are those from age 67 when he produced
his most well-known and characteristic
still lifes of apples views of Mulsanne
victoire and so on unlike Picasso
Cezanne did not often did not sign his
paintings had little concern about
marketing or selling them and almost
never considered them finished instead
viewing each one as a closer and closer
approximation of a way of capturing
perceived reality in other words as an
experiment that emerged under his brush
rather than as a theory or concept about
the nature of perception such as the
Cubist idea before applying this theory
to the academic career I want to take a
moment to appreciate the creativity of
Galen sins own achievement his work as a
fine example of scholarly innovation at
its best no one before him had ever
believed that the relative greatness of
art could be turned into a quantitative
measure what was it that allowed him to
make this novel discovery as he himself
says it was that while he was writing a
thesis on economics in college he also
took an elective course in the history
of modern art and for a term paper there
wondered whether there might be a way to
evaluate art by looking at its market
prices recording in the ledgers of the
great auction houses he went on to do
that study turned out there was
something to it and he spent the rest of
his life proving it and if you read this
wonderful book he talks about not just
the picasso and Cezanne he goes through
a number of great modern artists and he
then turns to writers film makers
scientists all kinds of people and shows
that the same pattern applies
this that is the fact that he was taking
a course in art history and in writing a
thesis in economics at the same time is
a fine illustration of the process that
Arthur Kessler in his rather neglected
but nonetheless brilliant and masterful
book the act of creation posits as the
essence of creativity in both art and
science what he calls the by association
of two hitherto incompatible matrices
when in reverie dream fantasy
imagination or an inspired moment a
prepared mind juxtaposes one matrix or
organized set of concepts encodes with
another the result can be a genuinely
novel entity thus in Galen's ins case
the fact that he was studying art
history at the same time as he was
immersed in the field of economics
created the favorable situation in which
his mind was able to think the two very
different fields together in a way that
produced a scholarly breakthrough there
can be no stronger argument I think of
the value of a liberal arts education or
indeed of a university that does not
merely train students in a technique or
an algorithm but exposes them to a range
of modes of thought so that some of them
at least will unite in creative and
productive ways what they have been
taught a recent sociological study of
institutions that had nurtured the
largest number of Nobel laureates and
other high achievers in science and
scholarship discovered that a key factor
in each was that they encouraged people
from different disciplines to come into
regular contact with each other
underscoring the power of Kessler's key
insight about creativity at Caltech for
example they have a weekly lunch at
which you're required to sit next to
somebody who's not in your department
and if I may go on to say so one could
say that the emeritus college itself
provides a foundation upon which just
such an institution can and should be
developed since it does bring together
in productive juxtaposition scholars who
have devoted a lifetime to a field in an
environment in which they can be exposed
and stimulated by the thoughts and
accept
variances of colleagues from other
fields of study I wish you well on that
project I'll be joining you shortly but
to return to the question of creativity
in the academic career I believe it
could probably be argued that most
professors fall into the experimentalist
style of creativity rather than the
conceptual on in Galen sins terms there
are of course exceptions in certain
fields such as mathematics theoretical
physics and some others of the more
formal sciences are often characterized
perhaps unfairly as ones in which the
best work is often done early on it's an
old saw in administrative circles that
in those fields it might make sense for
say a brilliant mathematician to begin a
career as a full professor gradually
devolved to being an associate professor
and end up as an assistant professor
instead of the other way around as an
example one can think of someone like
James Watson who was 25 when he
discovered the structure of the double
helix along with his colleague Francis
Crick though he had a long scientific
career he never again came close to
equaling that paradigm altering
achievement but of course how could he
such discoveries only come along once in
a century much the same indeed could be
said about Einstein or Newton both of
whom made their great conceptual
breakthroughs in their 20s and then
spent long careers rife with achievement
like Picasso's but without ever matching
those earliest great contributions by
and large however it is my impression
that most scholars and universities
conform to the model of the old masters
referred to in Galen sins title who
mature and deepen in their thinking and
are sustained by an engagement with
their subject matter that motivates them
to keep experimenting and pushing
further with problems that intrigue
provoke and animate them rather than
reorienting the paradigm with one great
conceptual coup and then waiting usually
in vain for a comparable inspiration to
strike again if that is so and while of
course there is tremendous individual
variation it seems possible to propose
that scholarly creativity in both
teaching and research and for those who
administration is something with the
capacity to maintain itself and at best
increase without break over the cause of
a course of a scholars career so that
answers the question of how long one can
keep it up from the point of view of the
motivation and ability of individual
professors living out a career
trajectory devoted to scholarly pursuits
but the answer to the question from an
institutional and even legal point of
view is while far simpler much more
problematic it is just this as long as
they please in contemporary American
universities the combination of two
factors lifetime tenure and the absence
of a mandatory retirement age combined
to produce a situation in which
professors can remain on the job at full
pay at will and the institution has no
power to do anything about it with
increases in longevity in the extending
of health and vigor in optimal cases
until later in later ages with improved
health care and healthy lifestyles and
given that the work is of a sort that
indeed benefits from a previous lifetime
of experience and reward the ones who do
it with great inner gratification there
is very little incentive for anyone to
give it up unless move to do so either
by negative factors such as physical
decline or positive ones such as a wish
to spend unencumbered time pursuing a
vocations enjoying family and friends or
enjoying life in the myriad ways in
which it's possible to do that now
opinion is very much divided these days
over the question of whether this
current institutional arrangement in
fact benefits the university students
and the wider community or whether it is
in fact a privilege that really only
serves the self-interest of the
professorial which puts forward
high-minded claims about the necessity
of the system really as a smokescreen to
protect and khushi cynic your enjoyed by
almost no other sector of society it is
to this thorny question of academic
tenure that I now want to turn my
attention many of us may in fact take
the question of tenure to be a settled
issue but it is not
in 1995 as I'm sure most of you know the
Regents of the University of Minnesota
attempted to put in place new
regulations that included weakening the
inviolability of tenured appointments
touching off what became known there as
the tenure wars in the end tenure was
retained in the same year the state
legislature of South Carolina considered
a bill to eliminate tenure from all
state educational institutions including
the University of South Carolina on the
grounds that it was an inefficient
business model while the bill never made
it out of committee the fact that the
suggestion was raised at all and
provoked a stinging rebuttal from the
head of the state's Commission on Higher
Education shows that the matter is far
from settled once and for all journal
articles debating the merits or lack
thereof of the tenure system are legion
in educational circles and I myself have
heard fellow administrators opine
sometimes with distress sometimes with
eager anticipation that the tenure
system will probably be gone within the
next few decades we are all aware i
assume of the hue and cry that has been
raised against tenure for grade school
teachers in the current ongoing battles
over public employees unions and the
change in the popular stereotype
stereotype of the school teacher in some
sectors of the media from benign
altruistic underpaid nurturer of our
children to over privileged in
underworked union thug who's in
competence is protected by a lifetime
guarantee of employment has been Swift
and dramatic I want to focus here on two
recent books about the current state of
higher education both of which
forthrightly call for the abolition of
tenure for all university professors and
for the end of the abolition for the
reinstatement of mandatory retirement
the authors of these books can be no
meet by no means dismissed as marginal
cranks nor are they apologists for
either the corporate business model for
universities stressing financial
efficiency or nor are they apologists
for a right-wing ideology that denounces
university as hotbeds of tenured
radicalism mark taylor author of crisis
on campus
2010 is a distinguished professor of
religion and philosophy at Columbia with
24 books to his credit the authors of
higher education ? 2010 by andrew hacker
and his wife Claudia Dreyfus are
respectively a distinguished professor
of political science at queens college
cuny and an adjunct faculty member at
Columbia School of International and
public affairs and a regular contributor
to The New York Times but before
addressing their critiques of tenure
levelled by these thoughtful observers
it will be useful to briefly sketch why
tenure exists and what is its presumed
rationale as Taylor shows the idea of
the modern University was invented by
none other than the great philosopher
Immanuel Kant in his 1798 treatise
entitled the conflict of faculties in
that work cot distinguished between the
professional faculties which would train
those such as lawyers statesmen and
businessmen who would in effect become
servants of the state and what he called
the lower faculty today's college of
liberal arts which would be free of all
state interference would study and teach
knowledge solely for its own sake would
be able to sponsor thought critical of
existing institutions and would govern
itself by peer review with fear no fear
without fear of meddling by outside
authorities Kant's the erotic old model
was then implemented by the great
educator vilhelm von Humboldt at the
University of Berlin and the german
research university went on to become
the model for the american research
university in the late 19th century
first with the establishment of Johns
Hopkins explicitly on a German model
followed by the founding or
reorganization of universities such as
the University of Chicago Harvard under
President Charles Elliott and so on and
it continues to this day here at Emory
we have the same structure the German
university enshrined a principle called
layar freiheit freedom to teach that was
the forerunner of today's tenure system
in America imported along with the rest
of the Conte and Humboldt Ian model it
was recognized only informally however
until the matter came to a head
the case of edward ross an economics
professor at Stanford who in 1900 was
fired for publicly espousing such then
unpopular current but unpopular
doctrines as free silver a ban on
immigration from China municipal
ownership of utilities and the
presidential candidacy of Williams
Jenning Bryan perhaps his most fatal
move was to argue against monopolies and
in favor of closed public scrutiny of
the Southern Pacific Railroad which was
of course the source of the enormous
wealth of Leland Stanford senior who had
endowed the university in the first
place Stanford's Widow Jane Lathrop
Stanford who was the university's sole
trustee at the time insisted that Ross
be dismissed and the president David
Starr Jordan after whom Jordan Hall
which I'm sure many of you have visited
complied this provoked several of Ross's
faculty colleagues to leave Stanford in
protest and themselves become embroiled
in similar disputes elsewhere one
William Fisher for example was fired
from Wesleyan in 1913 for supporting
relaxation of the Sabbath and stressing
the importance of good works over church
attendance that same year another
refugee from Stanford Arthur Lovejoy
then at Johns Hopkins rallied several
colleagues to form a national
association of professors to protect the
principle of layer freiheit two years
later in 1915 the American Association
of University Professors came into
existence and issued the 1915
Declaration of Principles identifying
three distinct elements within the
overall rubric of academic freedom these
were and I quote freedom of inquiry and
research freedom of teaching within the
college and university and freedom of
extra mural utterance and action in 1940
after the American Association of
Colleges weakened some aspects of the
1915 declaration a new agreement was
reached which established the principle
of the probationary pre tenure
employment period and made all
dismissals for cause
and subject to a trial procedure in
which faculty peers would be deciding
votes the 1940 declaration is the basis
of all tenure practices in American
universities today the cause for which
you can be dismissed usually are very
limited to either failure to perform
your duties moral turpitude or I must
say being a Dean having read the fine
print any other cause very seldom
exercised as Gregory Dickinson in his
excellent brief history of the tenure
system points out the effectiveness of
the declaration came about in part
because it was seen as part of a much
larger unit unionization movement during
the early years of the 20th century that
sought to erect all sorts of protections
of employees of all kinds against
exploitation and peremptory or arbitrary
dismissal by employers that it was in
effect the formation of a tea that is it
was in effect the formation of a
teacher's union although the Supreme
Court decided in 1980 in the National
Labor Relations Board versus the achieva
decision that college faculty members
were management not workers and
therefore could not form unions the
moral force of the aaup together with
the fact that any university that on its
own chose to do away with tenure would
not only receive heavy criticism but
would lose market position in the
perpetual chased after the best and
brightest professors have served to
maintain the real teeth in the
guarantees of job security afforded by
the tenure system in the nineteen forty
declaration two different rationales for
tenure are enunciated one is that
without tenure the academic profession
will not be able to attract men and
women of the best quality and thus
optimally serve its students and society
this was a key argument made for
instance by david loop the head of the
south carolina commission on education
in opposing the proposed 1995 bill to
abolish tenure there south carolina he
showed would lose competitive advantage
in attracting strong scholars and the
result would be a decline in
search income for the state so this was
a basically a financial argument this
argument for tenure along with the
self-protection dimension embodied in
the Union like positions defending job
security may be thought of as the less
less high-minded if also perfectly
reasonable defenses of tenure there is
also however the more noble and
idealistic rationale for tenure stated
in the nineteen forty declaration in
these words quote freedom of teaching
and research and of extramural
activities according to this rationale
tenure protects not only the professors
themselves and the competitiveness of
the institution not to mention the
economic advantage of the community but
also society at large from what then
does tenure for professors actually or
in theory protect society this is where
the critiques of the tenure system such
as those leveled by Taylor and hacker
and Dreyfus are at their most cutting
Taylor for example in addition to
arguing that tenure is simply a perk
unfairly enjoyed by only this one sector
of the employed population and that it
is economically inefficient since it
requires universities to spend large
amounts on the high salaries of senior
professors when they could be hiring
less expensive junior professors takes
on the academic freedom argument with
these words quote the traditional
defense of tenure is academic freedom in
the absence of tenure the argument goes
professors would not be free to express
controversial ideas new ideas that
question conventional wisdom without
fear of dismissal but on the basis of my
experience this argument is completely
without merit in 40 years of teaching I
cannot think of a single person who was
more willing to express his or her views
after tenure than before important other
critics have gone farther and argued
that in the pre ten-year period junior
faculty members much must actually get
into the habit of not crossing their
tenured college colleagues by stating
unconventional conventional ideas so
these colleagues will support them
during their tenure review thus it has
claimed tenure actually discourages
rather than encourages real originality
likewise it is often argued that
tenure actually serves to lessen the
incentive of those who hold it to be
productive to be less productive as as
they would be if they had to pass a
regular review of their work in order to
hang on to their jobs hacker and Dreyfus
for their part after reassuring us
readers that of course they favor
untrammeled inquiry in the unfettered
pursuit of truth right that such claims
as that tenure exists as a New Jersey
Superior Court ruling put it quote out
of concern for the general welfare by
providing the benefits of uninhibited
scholarship and it's free dissemination
though they have a plausible ring that
recording now hacker and Dreyfus do not
themselves show why this desirable
result can be ensured only by the
protection of employment for the
professorial like Taylor they write that
quote we have scoured all the resources
the sources we could find including the
ACLU and the AAA you see AAUP and yet
could not find any academic research
whose findings led to terminating the
jobs of faculty members we're referring
to research that chemistry professors do
in chemistry geologists do in geology
and English professors do in literature
by this last caveat which is central to
their argument they are ruling out cases
in which professors are dismissed for
expressing unpopular opinions not
related to their field of inquiry this
is a whole huge issue which I don't have
time to delve into I have very strong
feelings about it we can if you want to
we can discuss it later and they go on
to list three such cases a professor at
an Alabama college who blamed the
president of the college for falling
enrollment in poor morale in a local
local newspaper article a professor at a
Baptist University in Ohio for failing
quote to maintain consistent biblically
appropriate spiritual interest and
effective Christian relations within the
university family and an engineering
professor in Idaho who sought a
no-confidence vote in his president
these authors then conclude that three
features of these three cases stand out
first they all lost their jobs to the
tenure didn't actually protect them and
three the acts of speech that got them
in trouble did not involve their actual
teaching or research in their academic
specialties you could question that in
the case of the Baptist teacher I don't
know what he was a professor of but
sounded like one could make that
argument since anyone in any profession
might get into trouble for criticizing a
superior or failing to abide by
principles espoused by the employing
institution hacker and Dreyfus argue
that quote it is quite a stretch to say
that because being a professor is their
occupation everything they do must
become an exercise of academic freedom
criticism of a supervisor doesn't take
on any special status because it is
leveled at the head of a college rather
than say the editors and insurance
company we would only add that there are
another 300 million residents of this
country who would very much like to
express themselves without hindrance or
penalties we hope it won't be argued
that professors need broader and more
vigorous protections for speech in and
out of their workplace than accountants
or dentists uncool like Taylor they
suggested professors can and should
defend their right to speech on the
basis of the First Amendment like
everyone else not on the basis of some
special dispensation granted to no one
else except federal judges both Taylor
and hacker and Dreyfuss argued that to
deal with 21st century challenges
including globalization the ongoing
revolution in communications technology
the non viability of most university
business models in the current and
foreseeable financial climate the
mobility of the workforce new and less
linear patterns of life and work for
younger generations and other
considerations the university must be
nimble and the tenure creates a kind of
sclerosis that prevents the infusion of
new blood and a quick response to new
ideas and circumstances since so they
claim the arguments for ten years are
either bogus in the case of the argument
about freedom of academic teaching and
inquiry or merely self-serving and
unfair to the millions who do not enjoy
tenure protection there is therefore no
reason other than stodgy pneus and
self-interest both at the level of the
individual and the university that
that's where the stodgy
central self interest is to retain the
this tenure system and they both also go
on to call for the elimination of
unrestricted employment that is the
argue in favor of mandatory retirement
at age 70 it should be they argue
replaced with contract appointments
leading to periodic review which would
both ensure a higher level of
post-tenure performance and or weed out
those who are no longer performing up to
standards these arguments deserve
serious consideration and indeed they
sound very plausible and I will admit as
a Dean I have had my moments of wishing
tenure weren't there but in my view they
are profoundly wrong for a number of
reasons the first group of these are
internal to their arguments the second
group of concerns are graver they have
to do with what I perceive as the public
good that the research of tenured
faculties at research universities
provide and the sustained threat that it
is under in the contemporary political
arena to begin with Taylor's assertion
that in his 40 years he has never
account encountered anyone who was more
outspoken after tenure than before I can
do no better than to quote Taylor's
colleague Jonathan Cole the longtime
Provost of Columbia Cole writes quote I
don't know where Mark was hanging out
over those 40 years but he surely was
not considering the repression that has
periodically taken place at our great
universities these episodes include the
McCarthy era when only tenure prevented
many professors from being fired and
many untenured professors were in fact
let go and some new people to the civil
rights era when faculty members risk
dismissal for favoring integration in
some parts of this country or the
anti-vietnam war era when administrators
such as even the redoubtable Henry or
osofsky as he admits in his memoir the
famous Dean of Harvard were sorely
tempted to try to fire professors who
aided and abetted student protesters
rosovsky writes in his book that he
while he was sorely tempted to do it at
the time later in his reflection he's
glad
tenure was there and he couldn't even
though he tried in any event Taylor's
personal opinion about his colleagues
attitudes hardly constitutes anything
resembling a real argument the arguments
of hacker and Dreyfus are more numerous
but easier to refute being rather like
the arguments put forth in Freud's
famous course case of the person who
returned a borrowed pot in a damaged
condition arguing that a he had never
borrowed it be was already damaged when
he borrowed it and see it was in fine
condition when he returned it hacker and
Dreyfus is Dreyfus argue that in all
their travels they never met anyone who
was dismissed from popular views that
they encountered several people who were
dismissed for their own popular views so
tenure is not so great after all but no
one with tenure has ever dismissed
anyway and then at places like evergreen
college and others where there is no
tenure no one has ever dismissed ear but
of course they didn't come across anyone
who was fired because they were not able
to be fired precisely because tenure was
in place if it hadn't been quite a few
of them surely would have been fired
their argument that being fired for
problematic speech outside ones field of
study doesn't count that doesn't count
as inconsistent with the both the 1915
and the 1940 declaration according to
which extra mural speech and activity is
as protected as his speech or activity
in the classroom or in research
publication and we know very often that
one is the excuse for hiring somebody in
the other area in my view the opposite
is the case professors who do good
academic work but hold extra mural I
views at odds with prevailing norms or
opinions are especially in need of the
defense of tenure as for example the
case of Ward Churchill versus the
University of Colorado which is still
unresolved as we speak amply
demonstrates I could spend several hours
on the Churchill case but I won't if you
want to ask me about it all wax eloquent
in any event both books are altogether
too sanguine about what is at stake in
the debate over ten year in academic
freedom so let me be clear the public
good that research universities provide
for
society is the discovery and
dissemination of statements about the
world in the most general sense that
have been arrived at by methods and in a
spirit untainted by any sort of external
interest bias or pressure and are
recognized as such by the community of
scholarly peers who are the only ones
capable of making such a judgment
protected by the often derided ivory IV
colored covered walls of the campus from
the direct impact of the forces of the
market the work conducted in
universities especially by researchers
is guided by a prestige economy as
opposed to a monetary one and in this
respect stands apart from most other
contemporary institutions professors are
motivated not by the hope of financial
reward alone obviously people want to be
well-paid they want raises and so on but
that's not what they're mainly motivated
by if they were they would never have
gone to graduate school but by a
commitment to research that meets the
canons of their discipline and is and
for which they are recognized and
rewarded not necessarily with monetary
rewards but with honors which is why I
say it's a prestige economy society
desperately needs access to unbiased and
disinterested facts upon which to make
key decisions about all sorts of policy
at every level is the climate warming or
isn't it is the deficit going to get
worse or not we have to know the answer
these kinds of questions effects are
reduced to manipulable items in a larger
game of economic interest or political
power than any basis for rational
decision-making is rendered hopeless
that is why research integrity is in my
opinion the highest value that faculty
can hold and why in fact when people are
dismissed in my experiences for
violations of research integrity that's
the cry of a crime of crimes on my
academics yet the forces imperiling such
unfettered inquiry are many and
relentless donors funding agencies
outside interest groups of many various
kinds from all over the political
spectrum all have agendas to which they
attempt to tie their support or their
lack of it
for universities does not matter what
their agendas are but rather than it is
rarer and rarer for example in my
experience for a philanthropist to give
a large sum of money to a university and
say you're the best judge of what to do
with it and here let me acknowledge with
deep gratitude as one counterexample one
gift to Emory College recently made in
the de quest of the alum the late James
Varner which was in fact unencumbered
with any restriction but more and more
donors want to have a very clear sense
of what they want and are willing to
either withhold their funds if you don't
get it or give you a hard time these
forces of kev of course always been
there though they are growing steadily
in power and influence what is of
greater concern however is the fact that
powerful interest groups are targeting
the very idea of disinterested knowledge
all together with us have the spectacle
for example of large numbers of members
of Congress asserting that the science
indicating manmade global warming is
false or is false or not proven I'm not
asserting of course that I know the
answer to whether global warming is
occurring and is caused by human
activity but since I the Dean of a major
research university don't know this I'm
fairly certain that these Congress
people don't know either and
nevertheless are attacking the hitherto
widely supported legitimacy of the
scientific community and the scientific
method itself in what is very obviously
the self-interest of well-funded
corporations and individuals who profit
from the production of fuels that emit
greenhouse gases and who donate
generously to the election campaigns of
these same legislators we also see the
establishment and growth of in
legitimacy in the public eye of
privately funded think tanks that
produce research not guided by the
principles that guide university
research but by the economic and
political agendas of their founders and
in the mass media we see the conflation
of these two as if they stood on equal
terms we see the growth for of
for-profit educational institutions
guided not by any ethical concern but
only by the bottom line we see a
congressional climate in which cutting
one's not only for the perpetual targets
the NEA in the neh but also NIH and NSF
are on the agenda we see a u.s. senator
somewhat like Proxmire before him
grabbing headlines by very selectively
investigating the use of federal
research dollars by university
researchers more in the interest of
grabbing headlines than of creating good
research and most chillingly to me we
see a very troubling new development
namely the realization on the part of
some politicians that professors at
state universities are in fact state
employees like any other and can
therefore be placed under scrutiny for
their strict adherence to rules guiding
the conflict the conduct of such state
employees in everything from the
integrity of their research to their
public taking of partisan positions to
their use of their computers to let
their spouse know they will be home late
for dinner rather than for scholarly
research consider the case the fact that
the Attorney General of Virginia is
currently investigating possible
research fraud by a climate scientist at
UVA or the state Senate in Wisconsin
demanding the email files of a very
distinguished us historian who had the
temerity to write a historically true
account on the op-ed pages of the times
of the role of Wisconsin Republicans in
labor disputes in the past there was a
very positive article about the past
record of the Wisconsin Republicans in
this kind of thing I doubt whether these
professors will lose their jobs but that
is actually not the point the University
of Chicago's great president Robert
Hutchins who unlike the presidents of
other universities in the McCarthy era
refused to be badgered into turning on
his faculty pointed out the obvious
quote the question is not how many
professors are fired for their beliefs
but how many think they might be the
entire teaching profession is
intimidated unquote and if the teaching
profession is intimidated who will be
our truth tellers I believe universities
must vigorously recommit to support the
principles of tenure as a guarantee of a
guarantor of research integrity which is
as I
the highest value we as scholars hold
this is I believe this not in spite of
the criticisms levelled at the tenure
system or without recognition that they
are very convincing but precisely
because they are so reasonable appealing
and convincing and as I said I'm sure
I'm not the only academic administrator
or rosovsky either who in the late hours
of the night has not gnashed his or her
teeth and thought can I get past this as
hacker and Dreyfuss admit quote we
realize that the question tenure puts us
in strange company most to oppose it our
executives who abhor employment
guarantees of any kind or conservatives
who view it as the enabler of left-wing
correctness on campuses unquote they are
quite right the past several decades
have witnessed a concerted attempt by
moneyed interests in corporations
controlling outsized resources to
eliminate or devalue or otherwise weaken
any institution that stands in its way
in the way of unregulated unopposed
unfettered profit driven business
activity I am strongly in support as
anyone else of strong business
enterprise necessary for production
consumption and employment in a vibrant
economy but I like many others have
taken aback at the vehemence and
surprising political success of efforts
all it to undermine d legitimize or
destroy institutions that do not simply
support the economic interests of large
scale businesses at the expense of
employees not to mention the environment
and for good measure the search for
knowledge based on disinterested
research free of external interference
these institutions as Chris Hedges
argues that is the ones that stand in
the way of unfettered have free market
include labor unions independent media
mainstream churches and religious
institutions and the Democratic Party
and universities a list to which we
might now add the federal government
itself we are witnessing in today's
headlines the climax of the effort to
destroy you
onions we know that the vast majority of
media outlets are in no position to
question or critique corporate power
since they themselves are owned by and
agents of it we have seen put public
religious discourse usurped by a
particular ideology that glorifies
wealth and subjects the traditional
religious concerns of the mainstream
denominations of altruism service
concern for the less fortunate and
anything that can be labeled social
justice to mockery and contempt we have
watched the feckless pandering of the
Democratic Party and its inability to
articulate a clear vision to counter an
extreme n randiyan ideology all the
while collecting corporate backing from
the same corporate donors that support
both parties and we may as we may well
be on the verge of witnessing a deadlock
in the federal government that will
literally bring it to a grinding halt
the last one standing in short is the
University and calls for the abolition
of tenure no matter how sensible they
may sound or no matter whom they issue
from are in these circumstances nothing
other than stalking horses intentional
or not for a much less high-minded
assault that would D legitimize for the
blatantly self-interested purposes of a
small but disproportionately well-funded
and highly motivated minority of the
community the research integrity and the
spirit of open critique in the last
bastion with win within which they are
still reasonably well protected
scholarly creativity in later life can
be and usually is the rich culmination
of a lifetime of experiment and
experience on the part of individuals
who whatever their faults and they have
many it is true like everyone else are
driven by the pursuit of knowledge that
stands the test of the judgment of the
scholar scholarly community it should be
supported for that reason alone but the
safeguards that protect such scholars
from being intimidated or made to pull
their punches or hold their fire these
two need now more than ever to be
reaffirmed in the scholarly community
and by the society that benefits from
having genuine truth tellers in its
midst
Thank
thank you i gather its traditional yes
and academic freedom was very thought of
dying when very liberal relations and
similarly and others would try to put
aids the face of every from so i get any
freedom us to feel better just to point
out that for nds at least in my days now
there are many PhDs in the medical
school for 10 years much more normal
because in those days and even now it
can go out in practice and make more
than academics
secondly Wesley importance pant of
sabbaticals and I know it's venture that
I think it's a very very important for
Vicky Canyon professors because a young
though the opportunity of going on
sabbatical by Australians to go and
dominate all over the world are very
creative in their science and thirdly is
the possibility that we used to get the
kind of Professor that's still very
active in Europe at the age of 65 67 has
to retire I would bring them over here
very very limited amount that will spend
several months teaching and researching
and I think I propose this to Jim Wagner
three years ago I think that's an
excellent way to get really world-class
people to come to Emory and very cheap
and thank you for those comments us but
certainly it's the case that Emery
itself has a history about you know in
which there were unpopular opinions
expressed in a climate that was
different from what it is today but we
can take nothing for granted
I agreed Savannah well could be I'm on
sabbatical and I as greatest champions
great institution and it is true that
happened gracious and tailored both call
for the elimination of sabbatical leave
and safety want to write books you know
he had also what's the problem and so
that's it isn't thirdly we do in fact
have taken advantage of that for example
just to give one example David Ellis
very distinguished with a professor of
history here who's made the news many
times because of his incredible this
project he has recording the history of
slavery adjust from Africa to America
and document Dinis he's here because he
was in a Canadian university it was
forced to retire 65 and has done his
great work here so we benefited from
that but we have several examples I
could name right off the top of my head
at least four people who we got because
they were forced to retire elsewhere so
this was a different field quickly by
universal medical or having a quoted
experts
yes thank you for a very elephant in
scholarly lecture very convincing but I
wonder how you that you don't mind how
you personally feel about tenure for
teachers at the elementary high school
levels but they are teaching more or
less by protocol quite fine curriculum
as opposed to establishing developing to
know well that's obvious I assume that
we can ask that question and trying to
think of a way to avoid answering it but
the answer is I do not have the same on
an uninhibited enthusiasm for Kenyan
tenure for Bristol teachers or high
school teachers that I have for
university professor for the simple
reason that it's usually given for a
length of service rather than as the
result of a very very rigorous review of
research and teaching it's usually not a
demarcation of excellence of any kind
whereas the tenure review does in fact
in my opinion certified excellence what
opened my eyes more than anything else
in being a academic administrator both
as dean and as head of the T&P committee
was just how incredibly good quality of
our faculty is and also how rigorous and
not fair the review process really is
today I've just been very impressed with
that when I recently spoke with raw
informing the new dean who succeeded me
in college of arts and sciences he had
just finished guard from the whole
promotion process for the spring and he
couldn't stop raving about how just he
did have no idea we had such a
distinguished faculty and unless you see
a whole range of these cds just don't
have any idea nothing like that occurs
in schools that gives tenure it was put
in place back in the day when university
tender was established as sort of
thought world teachers that all t-shirts
should happen but while i can see both
sides of this and to some extent i feel
that both about the teachers unions and
about their opponents that my real view
is a plague on both your houses but all
in all I don't think that tenure for our
school teachers is in the same category
as Canada three errors and professors
plus my obstacle
oh that is one of the things and plagued
many young faculty if they put forth
effort in teaching and yet how do we
evaluate the effectiveness and I'm
talking particularly about those that
have to deliver lectures to class of
large class I'm not talking about
somebody the measures a graduate student
one of the accomplishments of which I'm
most proud in my many years of service
to every is that as chair of the
Committee on tenure and promotion I made
a policy that excellence in teaching had
to count equally with excellence in
research that's very rare most colleges
if they give lip service to that idea
they don't do it in practice that in
most places tenure is based research and
if you're an okay teacher fine you know
you really have to be pretty bad how to
do it however the question is not so
easy you can't send letters out to
outside people and say well you know how
good is their teaching because it's hot
sure they know where as you can do that
with their research but memory George
Jones who was prefer a professor of
chemistry and also Dean of the Graduate
School chair a committee that put
together a very very elaborate and
rigorous set of
for judging teaching at every one that I
think is not equal by any other school
and that includes not only a student
evaluation of teachers which by the way
in my experience is far more accurate
than people think it is even students
the students really think I was just
filling this thing out but if you
compare what they say with your own
impression of how these teachers are
plus the scuttlebutt about the man Henry
other criteria turns out there's a very
strong correlation between women's
teachers and students like and the ones
you think are going teaching and it's
not simply because they go easy grades
and really it's not the case but they're
also required to put in all of their
syllabi their tests there's a required
to be visited by senior professors in
their department who sit in on their
lectures and grade them on their
lectures give them feedback and if they
are inadequate or produce improvement
are required to undergo some kind of
teacher training through the various
centers for teacher training that exist
on campus in short the handbook that the
George Jones helped put together and
that we have lived by for these years I
think does it not as good a job of
evaluating teaching as it's possible to
do without being really intrusive one
also collects letters from former
students and all kinds of things and if
there are complaints one listens to
those as well so well it's less
systematic than the judging of research
it certainly can be done in a very high
level and my belief is that we not only
do it but we rewarded here and in fact
there are plenty of people who have
received tenure primarily on the basis
of really outstanding teacher teaching
as long as there
research is also in the very good
category and we also have a in the
college an institution that anyone who
has served as an outstanding teacher for
a very long period of time without
receiving a promotion because they've
chosen not to pursue a research career
can nonetheless be promoted to a
professorial rank similarly we just
instituted to you last year two years
ago the possibility that's senior
lecturers who demonstrated excellence in
teaching could be promoted to the rank
of Professor of practice or professor of
performance depending on whatever field
is so we do I think Emery is unique
among the great research institutions at
least the colleges in that it really
does place as high an emphasis on to
graduate teaching as it does on research
tenure is a small step you're concerned
about University tenure in its
preservation to continue to federal and
state laws in this country who
reportedly are paid at a 13 to thirty
percent IRA the average employee in this
country as essentially like long tenure
a great retirement program health
benefits and everything else that far
exceed the average employee and
adventuresome that is also a new juicer
and certainly a very great concern we
see it being played out in the politics
of the day absolutely once again I would
make a similar response to the one I
made about teachers which is that my
argument for tenure relied on the
importance of research integrity I think
that's not something that applies to
anything outside of university research
university frankly that research
integrity is the value that a good
society gets from its investment in
universities the question of whether
it's fair that public employees or you
want to receive in the case which I
gather as Trinity Arkin anyways that
they benefit excessively or more than
others you know some people would argue
in relation shouldn't get all that when
other people don't other people would
be well thinking everybody else trip too
that's a separate issue i'm not going to
weigh in as political issues of federal
state and federal unions which is a very
thorny issue but as i said to me the key
distinction is the same one that
separates college teachers from high
school teachers not only that it's not
based on length of service which is
usually the seniority which is usually
case with state and federal employees
but that it is there in order to protect
the research integrity of knowledge
that's produced by the society and
everybody in this society whatever their
political position needs in order to
make sound judgments
other ways in which universities could
be more creative thinking it was very
fascinating parallel with the study of
the artist and creativity may be coming
to its fullest
perhaps at the university's could be
more creative in treating older faculty
and recognizing that this crap is not
the same remember I'm doing much more in
the way of example suggesting lower
salaries for part-time work which is
free up my entire junior faculty at the
same time expecting that we're often
caught in a very wouldn't pattern here
and see your professors keep paid keeps
going up and up in fact you can start
drawing Social Security in this country
at certain time which would compensate
for the fact that salaries I know in
creative ways to it making sure you're
just not keeping Deadwood and I just
wonder what rule there is really when
you come across first thing I would say
is that yes there is the risk of
accumulating debt when you have tenure
and no mandatory retirement but I will
reiterate that in my experience the
number of people who have really just
sent back and done nothing after they've
gotten 10 can be counted on the fingers
one hand this is not a huge problem and
it's a very small price to pay it is
however true that people's interests
differ that is they may want to shift
their emphasis from writing or
researching to teaching or even to
administration and i think that the
university should be flexible and should
be able to allow people at different
points so i would certainly value
periodic review of people during their
tenure period not for the purpose of
kicking them out but for the purpose of
saying are you leading the most
productive life you can in this
university given your where who you are
where you are wicked thoughts are the
University Middlebury College has a
program where at a certain age I don't
have been maybe 65 I'm not sure whether
you can opt to become what they call I
think a faculty associate which means
that you receive 5 3 fifths of your
salary and you teach a slightly lower
teaching load and you can keep doing
that and you don't have to serve any
committees so that's a no that's an
example of precisely the kind of thing
that you're talking about and people
that I think we should probably explore
more ways for people who want to as they
become older to to think about different
varieties and ways of integrating a lot
I think for example of the fact that if
you are a laboratory scientist you have
to really believe act on the idea that
you have to stop accepting accepting
graduate students under you about five
years before you
to retire because otherwise you know if
they're going to come to work with you
when you retire that's not fair to the
student so there's this five year period
when you're a senior professor of some
laboratory science and you're not
teaching graduate students which is
where a great a bunch of the emphasis of
their work most of these people teach
more undergraduate courses or should
there be another way that they can
organize their lives I do think that the
university needs to be far more creative
I do however believe that needs to be
within the respect for the institution
tenure involve any diminution of I'm
just a wife not a faculty member
situation what happened if any more if
you if you keep on all retire I didn't
love this idea gradual diminishing
accepting the life of retirement because
it's quite a shock it comes all at once
but there also has to be room for
younger faculty people coming in to keep
the university alive and it has struck
me that
last graduation to which my husband the
class graduation attended there was
absolutely no one from a mr. department
clear all the younger faculty members
are so busy being on committees doing
their research their teaching that and
then trying to have families that the
pressures off of our medicine I'm a New
Yorker I mean I mean used to love
pressure being part of life but I just
wonder if the human asst of the
University of the whole wonderful rigor
thank the concern that people preparing
for a tenure review are a high state of
anxiety and stress whole miserable
experience is true has always been true
and it certainly not be lessened if you
didn't have tempered that is if you had
to be reviewed over seven years you
would have the same experience you know
five or six times over rather than just
any loss so so both Taylor and half of
drapes made that suggestion I think it's
completely to say all these people
suffer so much from having to be
subjected to this tender yeah right I
mean is it says stop I'm not saying much
no I'm very well I'm violence if I'm
agreeing with your point that it is very
hard on the people and it's especially
hard if I may say so on women who are at
their peak reproductive years just
and this is all supposed to be had and
so I it's been one of my main concerns
that I've never been able to really
figure out what to do about that how to
adjust the 10-year cycle to a woman's
life trajectory which is not necessarily
the father's play you know important
roles obviously too but they are not in
fact pregnant and so on so we you can
see all the problems that are there and
I didn't get into this but it is a sad
fact that while about fifty percent of
our assistant professors at this point
are women the month is representatives
way down you reach the full professor
level and why that is I don't know a
very high number of those full
professors are people women who are you
not married never married children so I
think we go eat to think about how can
he resolved management I also certainly
think that we do need to provide ways
for people to step down gradually but i
don't think that placing limits on
people even though it has costs I think
about is a row I fear that on this
wonderful market an issue that we've had
less run out of time and even a very
practical sense of
love the space
and have to passively call us to the
clothes that we have a two months to
express our gratitude office wonderfully
the challenges of the theme of
creativity came home to me when I was
thinking about a creative way to say
thank you and I called in some
assistance from John gunmen and her
banario and others and please accept
this gift from the emeritus college as
an expression of our gratitude for your
presentation today and we hope it will
give you some hours of listening
pleasure oh okay well that's a good hint
thank you very much which was certainly
not necessary but the gratification of
addressing you as a pleasure but
certainly much appreciated and once
again thanks to you and John to Mantua
and jog and to all of you for
participating
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University